[Musique]
combien existe-t-il d'espèces de saumon
au canada 6 le saumon de l'atlantique et
les cinq espèces de saumon qu'on trouve
sur la côte ouest certaines jusque dans
l'article le saumon de l'atlantique est
de loin celui qui est le plus consommé
pourtant à l'état sauvage les stocks de
saumon de l'atlantique se sont effondrés
il n'est donc plus pêcher
commercialement depuis la fin des années
80 mais une immense industrie de
l'aquaculture a pris le relais et
étonnamment la province championne de la
production de saumon de l'atlantique est
aujourd'hui la colombie britannique
l élève près des deux tiers des saumons
de l'atlantique produits au canada
outre cette espèce seuls les saumons qui
n'a échos sont élevés dans des parcs en
filet mais comme il supporte mal les
fortes densités des fermes d'élevage et
croise moins vite que leurs cousins de
l'atlantique
ils sont moins rentables il représente
moins d'un pour cent des saumons issus
de l'aquaculture au canada quant au
saumon rose ok t'as eos hawkeye
il existe des écloseries pour ces
espèces qui servent à l'ensemencement
des rivières cela permet le
renouvellement des populations et peut
favoriser la pêche commerciale en mer
mais ces trois espèces ne sont pas
élevées à grande échelle en captivité
[Musique]